[Applause]
[Music]
so all of us with desert sands and heat
the saara is one of the most
inhospitable places on earth located in
North Africa a half arid hostile
infertile and perhaps irrelevant place
these days it doesn't even have a
strategic value in international
geopolitics a first glance the Sahara is
little more than a desert the largest
one on our planet but of course this is
visual politic we don't do deserts here
in this video we will take a look at one
of the most forgotten conflicts in
international politics oh you heard of
the Western Sahara many of you may have
but I'm sure there are others who have
no idea what I'm talking about
Western Sahara is located just south of
Morocco and is the largest of the 17
non-self-governing territories currently
recognized by the United Nations Special
Committee 4d colonialization we're
talking about a territory with roughly
the same area as the United Kingdom
about two hundred and sixty thousand
square kilometres but with just over
half a million inhabitants the
population is around 550,000 people with
more or less half of their total being
these so-called Sahara people
historically nomadic people due to the
harshness of the environment that were
forced to constantly move from one place
to another
today for many it is one of the last
great stateless populations to exist in
the world now many of you will be asking
why it's a place seemingly as
insignificant as this so important why
is the talk of Sahar we people men's why
is only half of the territory's
population identified as such why on
earth is visual politic bothering with
such an inhospitable corner of the world
well we're going to answer all of those
questions but before we do let's take a
look back at the history
[Music]
a transition point presenter is what we
know today as the Western Sahara was a
transit area between Morocco and Mali
over which the caravans of Commerce once
circulated it was the easiest way to
avoid the great Atlas Mountains this
characteristic of beings are more than a
transit territory together with its
sparse inhabitants and lack of fix
settlements made this place completely
subject to the control of its powerful
neighbors Mali Empire and the Kingdom of
Morocco for more than 500 years however
when these empires went into crisis and
trade between the two of them collapsed
no one at all was concerned about for
Sahara the sparse population its nomadic
lifestyle and the harsh conditions of
the environments made establishing a
functional government and almost
impossible mission not to mention a huge
waste of money
[Music]
for this reason the Sahara became a
virtually abandoned territory and
largely forgotten until one of the
former European powers turns its
attention back to it
[Music]
at the beginning of the 18th century
Spain began to take a special interest
in this region for two reasons
coastal fishing grounds that could
potentially be exploited and the
possibility of establishing Atlantic
ports closer to the Americas this is how
a relationship between Spain and the
Sahara gradually began to develop the
relationship that was fundamentally
based on maritime interests however with
the expansion of other European empires
into Africa let's just say that Spain
didn't want to get left behind and so in
1884 it claimed a greater parts of this
territory as its own
and not only that years later it formed
an agreement with France to formalize
the territorial distribution of the
Sahara which allocated an even greater
area of influence to Spain at least on
paper because the truth is that physical
occupation did not really happen until
well into the 20th century in facts not
until the 1930s
so this is how what we now know is
Western Sahara was shaped as the last
Spanish colony and it was a de facto
colony until 1975 when suddenly the
scenario completely changed
[Music]
bad execution bad outcome throughout the
dictatorship of Francisco Franco the
Sahara along with Equatorial Guinea was
something like sleep last order relic of
the Spanish Empire the last evidence of
a dying era of course the reality on the
grounds was more disappointing than
receiving a toy with no batteries this
suppose it Imperial grandeur was nowhere
to be seen except of course in the
national as discourses during the Franco
regime the truth is that's in the 1970s
the Sahara was nothing more than a kind
of pebble in your shoe a territory that
was difficult to maintain and from which
Spain obtained practically nothing
however throughout the dictatorship the
Franco regime held on to hope they were
convinced that sooner or later enormous
hidden riches would appear
[Music]
[Applause]
in fact after the discovery of some oil
and phosphate deposits in the late 1940s
a Spanish government collaborated with
foreign companies to conduct surveys
throughout the Sahara to give you an
idea more than 3 billion pesetas the
equivalent of 700 million euros in
today's money was invested in 1960 and
1961 but now the question is did Spain
hit the jackpot well yes and no the good
news is that at least 27 potential crude
oil deposits were discovered the bad
news was that at the same time oil was
discovered in Libya and in the North Sea
to places where it was much easier and
much cheaper to extract so of course no
companies opted for the Sahara and
resources the treasure existed but it
was just very expensive to extract hold
on a moment
because there was an exception Spain did
not want to leave empty-handed
let's say that you found a relatively
valuable asset that you discovered a
huge deposit of high-quality phosphates
that was very cheap to extract
phosphates are a raw material used
intensively in agriculture
[Music]
so suddenly ins by pure chance the
sahara landscape went from resembling
something prehistoric to the industrial
age between the late 1960s and early
1970s spain launched the book remind one
of the largest phosphate mines on the
planet
however initiating production was not
exactly plain sailing you see at the
same time the Polisario France was
fighting for Saharan independence
against Spain so what this group did was
repeatedly attacked the mining
facilities and the 100-kilometer bells
that allowed the mine to be connected
directly to the port since that was
where phosphates were exported from and
so the mine was unsustainable the line
suffered irregular production until 1973
and was not expected to yield profits
until at least 1978 of course by that
year Spain was no longer present in the
Sahara in November 1975 a Moroccan
civilian convoy known as the Green March
made up of 350,000 people advanced into
occupied Western Sahara the Moroccan
government seized the moment Francisco
Franco was dying and the Spanish
government was thinking more about the
transition of power than the constant
headaches in the Sahara
for these reasons Spain literally left
its posts in the Sahara as quickly as it
could
[Music]
Morocco gauged the situation well and
the move went perfectly not only did it
occupy virtually overnight all of
Western Sahara but it also took control
of the lucrative bakra mind that is
still operational today and produces
around 30 million tons of phosphates
every year in this way Morocco has
become one of the world's largest
exporters of this raw material each year
this mine generates more than 1 billion
dollars for the Moroccan economy income
which is added to the huge fishing
grounds in Sahara waters and the still
untapped oil deposits that with current
technology could begin to be exploited
in other words Morocco is not about to
let the Sahara escape
that is why independence for this
territory it seems impossible today
illegal purposes and in the eyes of the
United Nations Western Sahara does not
belong to Morocco but instead remains a
non decolonized territory and therefore
Spain is still regarded as the
administering power espana poorest
person a few readers in favor de la una
solución moot comment effectively
prevail a liberal determination del
vallès occidental in El Mercurio
disposition is compatible s el a carton
of us readers dependents no way not even
on the agenda the Sahara has a strange
status to say the least it's not
independence but it's not Moroccan and
it's not Spanish either at least not
completely
and if that were not enough the
territory is further divided into two
parts the western part is controlled by
Morocco and a narrow strip to the east
which extends along the border with
Mauritania and Algeria which is
controlled by the Polisario France and
it was this group the Polisario Front
that established a government in exile
in Tindouf Algeria in 1976 the
governments of these self-proclaimed
suwari Arab Democratic Republic the fact
is that today there are just over 50
countries that recognize this government
it is a full member of the African Union
and it aims to achieve international
recognition as a fully independent
Sahara however there is a small problem
despite trying to achieve this since the
1980s Morocco has gradually expanded its
control of the territory
[Music]
as you can see on map over the years as
it has expanded and consolidated its
dominance Rocco is built up to six
dividing walls to prevent the advances
of the Polisario France as a result the
organization has ended up limiting its
control to the most depopulated
infertile and resource poor parts of the
area
Rocco also knew how to play its cards
well on the international scene you see
the Polisario Front embraced so-called
Arab socialism so the Alawite Kingdom
Morocco did not find it difficult during
the 1980s and in the midst of the Cold
War to obtain the West support to carry
out its plans however the UN still
regards Western Sahara as a
non-self-governing territory pending
decolonization and Spain is still
technically the administering power why
while to find out the answer that we
have to travel to the Madrid Accord
signed between Spain Morocco and
Mauritania in 1975 just after the green
March
it's in those agreements that we find
the root of the problem in these
agreements Spain transferred
administration of Western Sahara to
Morocco and Mauritania
although Mauritania seceded from Western
Sahara only four years later hardly
surprising because it already had enough
problems at home the point is that the
UN does not recognize these Madrid
agreements as valid because it is not
permissible to transfer control of a
colonized territory from one country to
another without the voice nor opinion of
that territories own people that is
precisely why the UN decolonization
committee continues to see Spain as the
administering power and in that role
Spain is charged with carrying out the
process of decolonization through a
referendum but of course as you can
imagine today the role in influence of
Spain and the Sahara is weaker than that
of Marilyn Manson in the Vatican Morocco
is the occupying power and has full
control and this is where we come to a
critical question why doesn't the
international community simply a
recognize Morocco as the governing power
and leave Spain out of it well basically
because this would set a dangerous
precedent
let me explain on the one hand
recognizing Morocco as an administering
power would in effect mean legalizing
the occupation of territories by force
and without the consent of its
inhabitants on the other hands Morocco
has not shown the slightest intention of
carrying out any decolonization process
its objective seems to be the full
annexation of the territory
and no one really cares much about the
Sahara because well The Situation's been
bogged down for decades so Morocco's
legitimacy to occupy the territory is
not recognized but nothing is being done
to prevent it either that's the way it
stands right now but at this point there
is a question we simply have to ask what
is life like under the Moroccan
occupation well let's just say that
things don't look great for the Sahara
people on one hand Morocco has promoted
and allowed the arrival of Moroccan
settlers who already make up half the
population on the other hands the
Moroccan monarchy has established firm
control with total impunity and has not
hesitated for a second to suppress
political freedom as well as to curb the
slightest freedom of expression
this is what most international human
rights organizations are reporting for
example Amnesty International has
repeatedly denounced the systematic
violation of the human rights of the
Sahar we people and in this whole vs Co
Spain theoretically the administering
power stays silence and we're not
holding our breath that they will say
anything in the future either everything
points to Morocco doing whatever it
wants with Western Sahara and this
brings up some questions well what do
you think about the conflict will we
ever see an independent Western Sahara
should Spain assume its role and fight
for a referendum of the Sahara people
well leave your answer in the comments
below and I really do hope you enjoyed
this video please do hit that like
button if you did and don't forget to
subscribe also check out our friends at
the reconsider Media podcast and thank
you for watching if you want to learn
more about politics and world affairs
and here's some more of my lovely voice
come check out the reconsidered podcast
where we don't do the thinking for you
find reconsider @ww re consider mediacom
or on Apple or Google Play or your
favorite podcast
[Music]